buonasera a tutti anche io sono qui per
parlarvi tanto per cambiare di
innovazione
però visto che tutti quelli che mi hanno
preceduto hanno fatto innovazione cerco
di darle metterla sotto un faro diverso
ho sentito di un'italia che va male in
italia dove non si migliora
non c'è speranza un'italia che va a
picco
però io voglio vederla da un punto di
vista diverso c'è la mia preoccupazione
non è tanto il nemico le tasse la
burocrazia ma il problema è che questi
partigiani dove sono quanti sono questi
partigiani sono veramente pochi
cioè non si può vincere un nemico in
pochi gli innovatori oggi sono veramente
lari questo secondo me è il vero
problema dell'italia e voglio darvi una
nuova definizione di innovazione ne
abbiamo sentite tante stasera in america
dicono che l'innovazione è breaking room
and the kings cioè se non si rischia non
si può innovare per cui se i giovani e
qua oggi ne vedo veramente tanti non
decidono di rischiare
non andremo da nessuna parte cioè non
c'è futuro per l'italia se noi
innovatori non decidiamo di rischiare il
posto di lavoro o quello che abbiamo
studiato
cioè voglio dire non abbiamo nulla da
perdere oggi non c'è nulla da perdere
quindi come ci ricorda anche il nostro
amico fondatore di link ring non c'è
miglior momento per innovare che durante
la crisi
quindi questa è la prima notizia buona
che vi voglio dare oggi non c'è miglior
momento perché la competizione più bassa
si riesce assumere meglio e
l'innovazione internet in questi anni ci
sta dando delle possibilità uniche la
seconda buona notizia che voglio darvi è
che l'innovazione non viene dalle
aziende
ve la faccio molto breve ma in america
dicono che l'innovazione è in stampa
individuale cioè e per spiegarlo voglio
farvi citarvi un esempio google
riprenderò molte volte stasera google è
una delle aziende che forse investe di
più in innovazione
però se ci pensate android l'ha comprata
youtube l'ha comprata huber la quasi
comprata ci ha messo 250 milioni di
dollari loro più grande investimento
snapshots gruppo hanno cercato di
comprarle e ha cercato di comprare delle
aziende che sono fatti sono state fatte
da ragazzi
dagioni da individui quindi per tutta
una serie di motivi è il motivo
principale è che le aziende sono
bravissime a mettere delle regole ea non
prendere rischi cioè l'opposto di quello
che vuol dire fare innovazione
quindi la seconda buona notizia che vuoi
l'harvey oggi e che l'innovazione la
fanno le persone quindi la fate voi
la fanno i giovani che ho qua davanti
quindi start up easy questa è la seconda
buona notizia
la terza è che ogni mercato può essere
innovato qualsiasi anche i mercati più
statici hanno una breccia
l'unica cosa da fare è fare tanta
analisi quindi prendere un muro
osservarlo analizzarlo per mesi finché
prima o poi troverete una breccia
faccio degli esempi un po non solo web
abbiamo acceso la luce per centinaia
d'anni e cliccando un bottone quando poi
una persona qui non una company un
individuo inventa con wifi un sistema
per gestire luci di casa con un'app
vince e raccoglie più di un milione su
kickstarter stato uno dei progetti che
hanno dato anche il via kickstarter
pensiamo a un altro mercato nato settore
proprio statico paralizzato le sigarette
film finché poi cosa succede che una
società di hong kong 10 anni fa sviluppa
un brevetto di un farmacista cinese ed
ecco che un mercato bloccato come quello
delle sigarette viene innovato quindi
l'innovazione dappertutto basta
solamente guardare quel muro a trovare
la breccia non dimenticandosi una cosa
però che per innovare veramente non
bisogna inseguire quelli che sono i
bisogni delle persone perché bisogni
vanno sempre soddisfatti saranno sempre
soddisfatti da qualcun altro
i cosiddetti o cene azzurri e osceni
rossi gli oceani rossi quelli bagnati
intrisi del sangue la concorrenza della
lotta al prezzo più basso no per fare
per innovazione dobbiamo andare a vedere
quali sono i sogni i desideri delle
persone
quindi questa citazione di armi ford
spiega esattamente questo concetto
cosa ho fatto
ho preso un mercato un settore quello
del no profit e analizzato una sfera una
cosa molto importante lo profit che il
fundraising c'è la raccolta fondi senza
della quale una società no profit non
può sopravvivere per sviluppare per
trovare questa breccia sono andato in
america a san francisco non perché non
si possa fare in italia semplicemente
per non avere distrazioni e ho fatto
brainstorming er 6 mesi devo dire che
per sei mesi ho guardato quel muro alla
ricerca della breccia
non so se l'ho trovata forse però lascio
sempre prevalere il dubbio sulla
certezza questa un'altra cosa molto
importante la supremazia del dubbio
sulla certezza chi pensa di essere
uscito chi pensa di essere arrivato
chi sa se la dorme tranquillo poi muore
quindi una delle grandissime citazioni
che ricorderò sempre fondatore della
dixon quando gli hanno chiesto il
segreto del successo qual è la risposta
o panic or die a quello che è successo a
nokia probabilmente non si sono accorti
da leader di mercato che le innovazioni
avrebbe potuti spazzare via quindi
quello che ho fatto è cercare una
breccia
quindi questo è stato il mio progetto su
come rivoluzionare il nu profit cioè
aiutare le associazioni a fare raccolta
fondi
usando quello che io definisco oggi il
più grande e media del mondo cioè le
celebrities
perché se ci pensate tutti i personaggi
famosi se messo mettono assieme i loro
milioni di fan su facebook twitter e
instagram messi assieme sono il più
grande e media che c'è e quindi quello
che stiamo provando a fare è quello di
raccogliere fondi attraverso la vendita
di memorabilia la vendita di cene con le
star in backstage accesso e concerti
delle esperienze esclusive
non abbiamo inventato niente quindi non
abbiamo inventato un nuovo mercato
perché le onlus da decenni fanno decine
di gala mettendo alla
le cose delle vip l'unica cosa abbiamo
cercato di renderlo diciamo un qualcosa
che fosse online accessibile a tutti
quindi anche qua
l'innovazione è stato quella di creare
almeno in europa ci stiamo provando un
prodotto migliore e quindi su questo
progetto ci lavora una cellula di
innovazione a milano di 16 persone e noi
speriamo partendo dall'italia di
portarla all'estero
quindi questo però conosciuto san
francisco fatto un corso di start up
avevo 12 durato un mese avevo 12 mentor
al quale ho presentato il progetto
e sapete a quanti di questi era piaciuto
soltanto uno e mi ricorda un po la
storia di elvis con ha fatto il primo
provino che è stato bocciato e stato
detto torna a guidare i camion elvis
quindi non sempre qui io speravo di
essere nella nel cerchio di elvis non in
quello dei progetti sbagliati
però poi ho trovato una citazione di
paul graham
quello che vedete che forse uno dei più
grandi la vetrina top ten degli
investitori della silicon valley dei
grandi guru del web
colui che ha fondato guai combinati ha
investito in start up per primo come
aree bimbi dropbox probabilmente le
conoscete le usate è una cosa sua mi ha
colpito moltissimo e del quale del
perché mi chiedo come si fa a
riconoscere la vera innovazione è
difficile difficilissimo perché paul
graham disse una cosa disse come sono
stato ceco a non capire le potenzialità
di facebook perché facebook lo sapete la
sul mercato cercava e disse mi sembrava
la perfetta beh dai dias
c'è un sito di nicchia di studenti senza
soldi and fall wasting time per perdere
tempo che se ci pensate alla definizione
perfetta di facebook quelli mi sono
domandato come ha fatto il più grande
investitore della silicon valley a non
capire a non arrivare a questo
la risposta è stata che è estremamente
difficile trovare la vera innovazione
perché si trova nella metà di quei due
cerchi vedete c'è il cerchio delle good
e dias
che proprio perché sono buone sono
facili ce l'hanno in tanti anche
comprare case ristrutturarle venderlo
alla guida di a smau per questo ci sono
tanti che lo fanno è difficile non è
scalabile e poi c'è il cerchio delle bad
e dias
quindi quando ricevete critiche e vero
che innovando ho visto o sentito prima
qualcuno che diceva non andate avanti
anche se vi dicono che è sbagliato
attenti però a non essere il cerchio
delle bad e dias perché quelle neanche i
migliori team e possono salvarle quindi
la vera innovazione estremamente
difficile perché si trova nel cerchio di
congiunzione le cosiddette next big
things quindi è là che vanno tutte
quante i grandi progetti perché sono
quelli che sono estremamente difficili
da capire all'inizio quella è la vera
innovazione e in quel pezzo di cerchio
ci metterei un'altra cosa molto
importante
come capire una grande innovazione
dovete sempre cercare una cosa perché
tutti i grandi progetti hanno un
elemento superficiale ma determinante
cioè hanno un qualcosa che agli occhi i
nostri delle persone normali sembra una
cosa superficiale ma in verità el secret
source c'è il segreto del successo
siccome abbiamo poco tempo ci siamo
soltanto un esempio google quindi google
non sarebbe oggi google se non avesse
fatto una cosa superficiale ma è la
pagina bianca de blank page google
andava contro tutti gli altri motori di
ricerca che avevano le news le mail pd
banner quindi ha fatto una cosa di srap
tve era la pagina più veloce a caricarsi
e lo è ancora ma pensate con aromi 56k
modem
ecco quindi ecco il motivo per cui
google non metterà mai pubblicità nella
sua home page perché il loro segreto
elemento superficiale ma determinante
così come tutte le altre start up per
instagram è stato il filtro vintage per
facebook è stato il imporre agli
studenti di mettere il nome cognome non
ci fosse stato quello facebook non
sarebbe diventato social network del
grafo sociale
ecco quindi quando cercate di innovare
cercate sempre l'elemento superficiale
ma determinante
che farà la differenza da tutti quanti
concludo dicendo che il fondatore di
virgin della virgin richard branson dice
che l'idea di business sono come i
pullman cioè loro passano basta soltanto
rimanere alla fermata giusta e io credo
che sia vero e di lancio dicendo che
l'innovazione come un'onda si può fare
sulla spiaggia sdraiato a prendere il
sole tra comodi
oppure si può prendere da tavola da surf
farsi male rischiare però se si è capaci
si può arrivare lontano
grazie